In the last episode, we had a bloody brutal fight against Ludwig.
And at the start of that fight, do you remember this guy ?
He was the corpse that came towards us in the opening cutscene.
Well, on my second fight with Ludwig on a new character,
I discovered that it's possible for this guy to survive the fight.
He didn't get hit once as Ludwig stumped all over the place.
Of course, all of my attempts, just think about how unlikely that is.
He is probably laughing here like what the fuck how did i survive that ?
On my other character, this guy is dead, even during the fight with Ludwig that are still ongoing.
So i guess you get one chance to save his life.
And while i'm busy discovering all these pointless things, you guys are finding some really cool stuff
Commenter AKnaught92, in the last video, found something particularly awesome.
If you talk to Ludwig's head after the boss fight, while wearing the garb of the Healing Church,
the he says this:
"Tell me, good hunter of the Church."
"Have you seen the light?"
"Are my Church Hunters the honorable spartans I hoped they would be?"
"Ah, good...that is a relief."
"To know I did not suffer such denigration for nothing."
"Thank you kindly. Now I may sleep in peace."
"Even in this darkest of nights, I see...the moonlight..."
I guess i didn't have the heart to tell him that his Church Hunters are now blood raving lunatics
I'll be checking out what happens if you say no here though
It should make for some pretty sad stuff for prepare to cry, right?
Telling him that his life's work was for nothing.
But it turns out there is one blade of the Healing Church still alive and human in the nightmare.
"Shrouded by night, but with steady stride."
"Coloured by blood, but always clear of mind."
"Proud hunter of the Church."
"Beasts are a curse, and a curse is a shackle."
"Only ye are the true blades of the church."
He's reciting some chant that the Healing Church Hunters must have learned
to keep themselves sane while hunting beasts
the repetition would have helped with anyone's sanity
and he's not the only one who does this
The next two characters we meet, in fact, have their own little chance going on.
"Are you a hunter ?"
"Well, that's very odd."
"Do you hear the toll of the bell."
"Hmph. Liar. Such pettiness will be your undoing."
"The beasts you seek will not be found here."
Go back to your hunt, and if you have the chance, put this night behind you."
"...places better left untouched, secrets better left alone..."
"...only a fool would so brazenly roam..."
We're going to hearing that bell before too long,
and it turns out it's not a sound you want to hear.
At the end of the hallway, we find the Fist of Gratia,
which belongs to this hulking brute of woman who didn't have the dexterity to wield firearms.
And up ahead, we run into someone very familar
This is almost certainly Vicar Amelia, right ?
It's the same chant we hear before her boss fight.
The voice is the same, and it's her white garb.
I'll be at less raggedy since this is based in the past, i think.
We know that blood-crazed hunters ended up in the nightmare.
So she must have ended up here when we put her to rest in the waking world.
You have to kill Amelia in the waking world before you can access the DLC after all.
As the eye pendant we found in the last video states,
this is the Cathedral of Healing Church that contains their the private research hall.
The Church and the Choir have long experimented on patients in order to gain insight and
potentially ascend to the status of Great Ones
that much at least is clear from the law we learned so far
and this research hall can hopefully tell us a little more about
"Has someone, anyone, seen my eyes ?"
"I'm afraid i've dropped them in a puddle."
"Everything is pale, now..."
Is this Eileen?
Listen to the way she say puddle
"Puddle"
Sounds like when she says hunter
"Hunter"
The accent is the same, for sure, and maybe the voice as well.
But beyond that, i guess we need a bit more proof.
Anyway, the gameplay in this area is interesting,
for me, it was the closest series has come to having a stealth based level.
I don't know if everyone else experienced this but i did.
Because all throughout the level, you find these Blue Elixirs, which is a medicine
that used by high ministers of the Healing Church,
to numb the brains of those they experimented on
and they're certainly appropriate here in this research hall teeming with patients, with enlarged heads.
Our character retains consciousness when they drink this through sheer force of will
And we make use of the secondary effect of the medicine, which is to go semi stealth
And I couldn't always be bothered killing every one of the patients
so often i would use blue elixir to scout out the level
and i had some pretty cool moments with it
Look at this guy run past
The Souls games are rare examples of games that actually reward you for being observant
some bookcases for example, have pressure plates in front of them
which when pressed trigger the bookcases to attack you
That's the sentence i never thought, I'd say
Also take for example, this huge winding stairway
some platforms you'll notice are inaccessible
which hints that staircase will rotate
later on and that you'll be rewarded for coming back and exploring again.
I just really like stuff that rewards the observant player.
And being observant really does reward you because the item you need here is the Loch Shield.
A shield with such low requirements
that pretty much any build can be able to use it
It protects you against non physical damage and it's going to be really useful in the next boss fight.
They've also done a really good job, i think of not just introducing new enemies
but variations on the same enemy.
I can't say the same for games like Destiny that charge you $70.
For an expansion with the same enemies and the enemies just have a different skin
No, in this game, there's tons of new enemies
and a lot of enemies like enlarged head patients, they all have vastly different movesets, meaning you're always guessing.
Moving on a little bit, the main law question for this area is:
What was the Church hoping to archive with these patients ?
So, let's listen to some dialogue:
"Is that you, Lady Maria ? No, you're someone else ?"
"Please, could you do something to me?"
"I need Brain Fluid. Murky, mushy Brain Fluid..."
You find this Brain Fluid on fully developed heads,
the ones that talk about the sound that they're hearing.
"Lady Maria, I'm a robin."
"Will I ever curl up and become a egg ?"
"What say you, Lady Maria ? Lady Maria ?"
"Say something, anything..."
"Have you heard how curiously the sea churns ?"
"Like the storm, but like the rain, only gentle, like dripping water..."
"It bellows, from deep inside of me..."
"Here it comes, up through my insides..."
"But gentle, like little droplets..."
The Brain Fluid reads: extracted from a patient whose head expanded until that was all that they were.
These heads and the patients that have them,
they're kind of insight experiments that you would expect from the Church.
Clearly, the things they're saying have some significance
they're all related to water,
they're not just ramblings of insane people.
The importance of large bodies of water is actually referenced in a lot of runes.
The lake rune, for example, say that they  serve as a bulwark guarding sleep, and an augur of the eldritch Truth.
They say that the transcription of the Great Ones' inhuman voices ripples like a watery reflection
They say that we must overcome the hindrance of water, and seek what is ours.
And in the next video, we'll learn a bit more about what this means
but just know for now, that these beings clearly have more insight.
Even though it's really specific, that these enlarge heads that hear the water and so will we, soon.
One patient that hasn't completely turned into a large head,
talks about being a failure.
As if she let down the Lady Maria, who all the patients clearly see as
some caring motherly figure.
One character in particular talks the most, she's called Saint Adeline
and we help her take three helpings of brain fluid
and then
"Ahh! Ahhh! I see a shape."
"My guide, I see your voice, clearly, as it bends and bleeds."
"My own, revelation...just for me..."
"Thank you, for everything..."
"Really, I used to be nothing..."
She's so proud that she became something, like she finally had this purpose .
She gives you the Milkweed rune if you complete her quest,
which turns us into this thing.
And also she gives us the Balcony Key,
which leads to the area that used to hold the celestial emissaries in the waking world.
It's more proof that these patients were trying to be turned into kin, or these celestial emissaries.
The Milkweed rune reads: A translation of the inhuman, sticky whispers that reveal the nature of a celestial attendant.
Sounds a lot like a celestial emissary.
Speaking of failure, this next boss, the Living Failure.
To me, these things and by extension the other creatures in the research hall,
they all seem to be attempts at creating celestial in some form
and maybe even celestial emissaries
beings that can talks or communicate with the Great Ones perhaps.
There are a lot of similarities, especially in regards to where you fight them.
It's an interesting boss, every time you take one out, another one spawns
and there's always going to be four of them attacking you from all sides.
They're incredibly slow but when you deplete their huge health pool,
they get bolder and more aggressive and more frantic.
At around 50% heath, they start casting Meteor Storm together,
which is best defended against using the lock shield that we pick up earlier
as it defends against arcane projectiles.
If you're well positioned, you can even get a backstab off while they cast the Meteor shower,
which I highly recommend because it's a way to get in that much needed damage.
After succeeding, we talk to the wandering hunter.
We're going to call him Simon for reasons I'll explain later.
"Oh, hello. Not a pretty sight, is it?"
"The true face of the blood-worshipping, beast-purging Healing Church."
"But that’s not all."
"You seek the secrets field by the Nightmare, do you not?"
"Then here’s what you must do."
"Climb the Astral Clocktower, and kill Maria."
"She hides the real secret…"
"A corpse... should be left well alone."
"Oh, I know very well. How the secrets beckon so sweetly."
"Only an honest death will cure you now."
"Liberate you, from your wild curiosity."
Lady Maria, so far, all we know is that she's a caretaker of the patients in the clinic
and that she hides the true secrets.
I am confident in saying that this was my favorite fight in Bloodborne so far.
I love hunters boss fight in this game, because they put you on
what seems like even footing with an opponent
and it allows you to make good use of the health regain mechanic
unlike most beasts enemies that just flatten you in one or two hits.
I hate that, i love when it's a fight where you can regain your health.
You can probably parry her but I wasn't gonna find out,
I feel like spamming parry is a really shitty way to do this fight.
I wanted to dash around and use my reflexes and my blades of mercy
and I just wanted to get through all of her phases that way
And as we're discovering every boss in the old hunters has phases, Lady Maria is no different.
She has three.
Every time i fought her, i fought one stage further.
I did this, because her phases are actually pretty well designed.
It's not like fighting Ludwig, where you fight a completely different version of him at 50% of his health.
No, Maria trains you in her attacks, every phases simply upgrades the attack that she's already been using.
Meaning that earlier phases train you for future phases, and they reward you for learning.
Such a good fight.
And I'll tell you now, Maria is going to make a fantastic prepare to cry story.
There is so much interesting stuff to talk about but we'll have to do it in another time.
Let's talk a little bit about it.
So as her set says she's an apprentice to Gerhman, someone who looked up to him
though he has an affection for her that she didn't seem to sense.
Since Gehrman modeled the Hunters Dream, it's clear that the doll is actually modeled after Maria.
This caretaker who shares most of physical attributes
Maria is a caretaker of the patients and the Doll is a caretaker of of us.
There's a lot of similarities there, not just appearance.
However, Gehrman certainly seems displeased with the Doll in the Dream.
And for a man who is supposedly created the Doll out of love for another woman,
he never interacts with her.
Perhaps it's because the Doll has a completely different personality.
Maybe it's because she's far less headstrong and way more subservient,
he couldn't replicate who Maria was in the Dream
But, yeah, lots to talk about, i'll see you guys in the next one
Thank you for watching and it's time to get into some secrets.